donc j'appelle ou trois petites choses
sur le nombre d'heures elle dit on
devrait avoir un contrat de travail de 1
mois parce que c'est un mois avec le
voyage ces trois jours elles disent qu
effectivement à ne sont pas nourris à
10,4 contre plein plein de photos de 6h
à 22h elle travaille pendant que la
production se met face à face mais plein
d'argent dans les poches à qu'elles ne
sont pas payés elles disent qu'elles
doivent commander même des plateaux
repas ou de la nourriture en loucedé
parce qu on les nourrit pas assez parce
qu'il faut qu'elle reste mince bref elle
se rebelle elles sont pas contentes
alors est ce que tout ça est vrai ou pas
april alors moi je laissais l'année
dernière voilà alors voulait revenir sur
la nourriture oui premièrement
alors qui a dit que c'était pire que koh
lanta ce je n'ai jamais entendu ça est
sûre tout anonymat mais c'était perdre à
moi personnellement quand j'avais faim
belge allait me resservir c'est pas une
honte oui évidemment mais aussi d'une
cantine ya un truc et on compte bien sûr
ça lui mettre des frites tout ça où bah
ça dépend des jours et bien non il va
pas s'améliorer y avoir à qu'on voit là
où on sera tous house et ses bassins
évidemment évidemment il va pas y avoir
des gaufres au nutella tous les jours
non je troll hébus gueuler des prix et
des frites et des métis et la journée
elles vont pas manger un truc mon côté
la bourse moi tu essaies miss france
miss normandie alors tu en aurais le
physique un très bel effet voilà donc la
nourriture on peut manger savoir aussi
que quand on arrive à miss france on est
mesurée de la tête aux pieds pour les
costumes le sort des élections tout est
fait sur mesure donc si on dit pas quand
tu manges non je parle de ça
donc si tu prends du poids et que tu te
laisses aller eh bien il va falloir
refaire ton costume ouais donc ça prend
énormément de temps il ya des coureurs
qui sont là pour ça surtout qu'il faut
rappeler april que donc avec le voyage
de presse et tout faire le voyage en
tout c'est un mois les mise donc sur un
mois vous pouvez prendre du poids voilà
les 287 euros qu'elle a pris sait pour
combien de temps alors trois jours et
trois jours de l'émission de l'émission
mais ça dure un mois et ça durera moins
avec un voyage préparatoire non mais on
remet les choses à leur compte et se
sont inscrits ces miss là il y avait à
la base pas de salaire oui
manara les pas normal le jury mais
feilhes les danseurs sont payés sous
meilleure conscience est un sacré
programme à quel moment les stars du
programme concours tu t'inspires alors
là c'est un pays où elles sont payées
hugo enfin sur scène je veux pas donner
mon avis mais hugo demain tu fais un
concours de beauté tu pourrais très beau
t'es payé pour le faire ah non là en
l'occurrence elles le sont maintenant
aider mais ce que je dis c'est que je
trouve que c'est pas beaucoup parce que
c'est les stars du programme c'est
l'événement dé payer les danseurs sont
payés sûrement bien ou bien plus que le
smic qu'on leur oppose le jury ait payé
je veux rien dire mais beaucoup et
l'émission fait combien de
téléspectateurs email rapport mais
millions des mâles combien il touche
grâce à sa carrière et touche 200 euros
pour deux jours c'est de l'argent qui
dézingue a même qui devait on est
couverte de cadeaux non d'abord dans cet
attentat est-ce qu'on peut revenir comme
sur abritel plus connaître donc tu
manges et bien effectivement pendant un
mois à faire attention à pas prendre de
poids bien sûr que voilà attention à pas
en perdre aussi les cadeaux on vous dit
que vous avez beaucoup de cadeaux
pendant bien sûr on n'a pas des
gagnantes à des cadeaux c'est quoi on a
tout ce qui est vestimentaire beaucoup
de maquillage tout ça pour se préparer
ce qui est normal pas les ipad 2 iphone
ou un ipad moi j'ai été dauphine donc
j'ai eu un iphone j'ai lu des revenus
ouais
c'est quand même beaucoup de choses et
puis c'est faut le dire c'est quand même
ce france est gênée la cour est l'autre
est ce que c'est vrai que dans les loges
ou pas c'est tendu c'était tendu entre
vous il ya la production et à peu va il
ya plus jeunes viable et la production
est un peu dur avec vous cette voilà ce
que c'est tendu alors je crois que ça
dépend des années mois de l'année ça
s'est passé hyper bien ouais les filles
étaient top donc je suis très contente
pour ça je sais que voilà il ya des
années bas évidemment il ya des clashs
mais évidemment ça se ça se marre un peu
mais c'est normal on est aussi là pour
une couronne donc et sur les heures de
travail le côté t on au travail de six
heures du matin parfois à 22 heures pour
faire des photos
tu as à dire non ça m'est arrivé deux
fois oui en un mois quand même d'accord
donc bon je trouve pas bon pour toi tout
ça c'est un c1 c'est un faux débat c'est
quoi ces trois miss en fait c'est 3000
ce qu'on fait ce
single loser oui j'ai eu envie de rien
j'appelle closer mais aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça que je ne comprenne bien que
j'appelle un méchant méchant méchant
j'ai eu alexia laroche joubert au
téléphone juste avant l'émission alors
discuté un petit peu de ça avec elle
elle est très en colère elle elle dit ce
que disait digital instance a produit
vient de préciser quels produits ont
collé là mais elle a mis en place un
contrat quand même un contrat de quatre
jours certes mais elle dit voilà un truc
tout simple le fameux voyage qui est un
voyage d'agrément elles sont pas obligés
d'y aller excellent veulent pas aller à
tahiti passé deux semaines de rêve
d'accord la semelle père de louis xi
autre chose de très important c'est
qu'elles ne sont pas lâchés même les
perdants c'est à dire qu'elle est
comités locaux miss périgord mis ce
machin etc pendant un an elles sont
suivies il se passe plein de choses et
norah jones et on leur propose six ici
et on leur propose aussi de de signer un
contrat avec la société talence large
part sous le contrôle de deux
pour être suivis en tant que deux en
tant qu influent second temps qu'un flux
en sauce développer son réseau et elle
sait très bien qu'elles ont un milliard
de deux fois plus de gagner qu'à perdre
mais non mais après ils apprennent un
beau être est ce que c'est vrai a pris
le kilomètre mettre aussi du coup
pendant un mois c'est ce qu'elles disent
sa carrière ou ou où ces projets ou ses
études ou sur métier
dans 20 ans jacques ailleurs c'est quoi
moi je faisais une école de commerce
sont émus s'annoncer entre parents
lettre des études comme celle lancée et
j'ai fini par l'ofii alors germé
ludivine et après on passe à un autre
sujet ludivine ben non mais faut arrêter
deux secondes alors j'entends depuis
tout à l'heure si anaky débat oui elles
sont pas formatés au gaschney français
c'est comme si tu viens tu tirais
travail ou quel que soit sur quoi tu
pourrais participer qui générerait de
l'argent il faudrait pas que toi tu es
une petite partie du gâteau mais non
mais en fait si moi je travaille où j'ai
des études et je les ai pas envie d
abandonner pour un concours j'y vais pas
mais sauf que là elle décide d'y aller
c'est elles qui font vivre le programme
c'est un mois dès 6 heures du mat ifo
est fraîche chérif lô est belle faut
être au taquet je suis d'accord
qu'effectivement il ya un effort qui
était fourni cette année mais c'est pas
un effort suffisant quant au smic alors
il vaut mieux qu'un s'adresse me de
marge ne faudra pas été fait l'interview
aura d'abord un personne ne vous force à
le faire le raf la belle n'aurait gagné
pas ça nous force à terre et puis deux
fautes et pour la qualité mais quand
bien même on nous force et on va le
faire c'est quand même un engagement
c'est du boulot il ya des répétitions il
ya des choses
il a pu notamment de jean michel2 fois
tahiti et deux fois j'ai été payé sa job
j'y allais pour mon travail pour le
figaro enfin reportages là bas
[Musique]
je me fais ton job d'être candidat
au national fiona
ces pays là c'est la société miss france
créatif c'est une société qui fait de
l'argent qui génère beaucoup de stress
énorme un titre
messieurs on a alors vu un mot je sais
que c'est faux être annoncés non non tu
peux disait que cette question elle
s'est posée longtemps pour les candidats
de télé réalité d'ailleurs j'ai présenté
du la tentation il ya très longtemps
c'est vrai une fois une année c'est ce
qu'on appelle la jurisprudence île de la
tentation c'est à partir de ce moment là
que des conduits à des taux bien foutu
la merde non ça n'a rien à voir c'est
moins sûr en 2010 qu'en 2004 quand même
promise est églament a été attaqué par
des conduits dans dix ans on a bossé et
il ya eu ces montées très haut jusqu'à
la cassation et au final depuis on paye
nous conte la plus primée la différence
mais laurent la différence c'est qu'à
connaître et est d'accord il a participé
à un programme qui va être diffusée tous
les jours c'est un peu comme un émetteur
des carnets hugo en a fait là c'est un
concours site ministre ans et que tu
gagnes pendant un an taxer à tout ta
carrière va changer derrière lui donc
c'est malheur au vaincu ya un gagnant
qui remporte tous mal gré
le loto continu du
gong est important mais non mais je ne
vais je vais répéter ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure mais si peut-être ya
quelques années mais pas autant que
téléspectateur je sais pas depuis
combien de temps
ça doit générer un peu doit générer
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent mais fait que
ça a donné un peu plus que le smic je
dis pas que qu'elles ont rien je sais
qu'elles gagnent tout des followers et
deviennent toutes influences heuzey sont
pleins de bonnes répercussions regard tu
es là april c'est génial mais est-ce que
leur donner un peu plus les escaliers à
la serbie qui ce qu'a dit alexia voilà
qui ont dit que le chien je trouve que
c'est une bonne avancée c'est pas parce
qu'à mon nom n'y avait rien en qui on
doit passer juste au smic voilà tu es
toujours je pense que ça va tout gâcher
ça va tout changer en avant et après le
après c'est que les gens extrêmement
certainement pas pour l'argent il y
avait quand même malgré tout il reste
encore la légèreté ma femme pour le rêve
c'est bizarre que personne ne claquez
sont ici en plus vous connaissons tous
quoi de l'institution mais miss france
quoi bien en espagne il ya une personne
trans qui est devenue miss absolument
grands univers il faut pas être tatoués
faut avoir une sexualité
alors non non non c'est un autre sujet
laroche joubert elle a dit qu'elle a
ouvert un peu la porte et on va l'espère
pas non piquée 54 ans qui tout de suite
nos marques allemandes calmos
dépénaliser dis ça mais si on peut
éviter d'avoir ce serait comme 3cb de
travaux sous une cape town
c'était beau mais tout à l'heure chez
jordan de luxe un paiement et sont bien
vrais soucis dont on va parler c'est
peut-être ça c'est cette représentation
de la femme tous les mois de décembre
sur tf1 où tu as quand même normalement
23 gonzesse qui se ressemblent et qui
sont tout
c'est pas dévalorisant pour toi mais
absolument pas apporté que du beau temps
de souffler qu'il respecte le plus quand
même appris à être est ce que vous
connaissez entre entre les différentes
promos celle de cette année tu les
connais un petit peu ou pas du tout j'ai
parlé avec quelques-unes ouais vous ça
va plus c'est le combat lancé
pour le derrière avec cyril seguy
très bon sa sirène qui produit et
penserait mais vous savez un petit peu
qui est ce que sur des fivois lac été
cliquée voilà depuis le début faisait du
mauvais esprit et tout ça où est ce que
les filles de cette année je les connais
pas je leur ai parlé après miss france
pour les féliciter parce que c'est quand
même un gros truc
par contre celle de cette année je les
connais tout et je sais comment elles
sont vous savez que guillaume guillaume
a filmé les miss je me trompe pas alors
j'avais fait j'avais suivi oui geneviève
de fontenay la dernière guerre
[Applaudissements]
sa passion dernier
son dernier tour de piste quoi et donc
j'avais fait avec dans la france toutes
les miss pendant un an j'ai suivi c'est
génial hein mais bon ma vie des vhu
marie yvonne à bien d'ici en revanche en
fait c'est tout de suite qu'il a gagné
énormément fait vous rentrez dans une
pièce vous voyez quand tu fais les
concours régionaux très souvent fait
après j'en ai fait bon en fait vriller y
en a une qui est plus solaire plus
machin vous voyez à peu près celle qui
va gagner après c'est un peu comme dans
les dé comme dans les coulisses les
backstage et défilé de mode celle que
vous allez mettre des choucroutes de la
bouffe et compagnie mais les filles
elles vont toutes aller manger des
pommes donc en fait elles veulent pas
grossir elle doit l'être fit donc
évidemment elles disent y'a pas assez à
manger on leur met beaucoup de choses
mais elles mêmes se restreignent pour
garder la ligne jaune est belle c'est
normal dans un concours y est c'est un
échange marchand si on les payait trop
j'imagine qu'on pourrait dire l adapter
à la tête reçu de l'argent en plus et du
coup elle a poussé match enfin on n'en
sait rien c'est c'est très bien roulé
pourquoi vouloir tout changer tout le
temps c'est un coeur en paix
avançait légèrement donné ses comptes et
moi j'ai trois filles c'est que quand tu
fais pas exactement comme ça que tu fais
63 kg parce que tu es une gonzesse et tu
fais un mais deux ans
à cause des magazines taco de la
télévision c'est à cause de tout ce
qu'on aime en famille ce qui a causé des
morts sera ta g qui fonctionne à 20
équipes est 12 kg
ils sont là s'aiment ils sont là ils ont
été cédés sélection dans les régions
c'est les gens des régions qu en beauté
j'ai bien compris c'est un entonnoir on
sait quand ça marche c'est paris et la
télé qui décide qu'on mais celle là
absolument